SM2
SM2加的全棉的这个黄色开衫
黄色开衫
有扣有扣牙
两边有口袋
但是呢
后面这里知真知错了
有一点点瑕疵
知真知错了
来这款咱们原来
是卖49的
现在你们谁要
给你们放福利吧
这个后面有点点瑕疵
来这一款
有扣有扣牙
两边有口袋
全棉的这个
这现在的话
在空调房那里可以搭一搭
胸围92 100
92 100
长度的话61
来这一款
谁要谁来扣
9块9块扣0
9块9块
谁要谁来扣个0
给你们便宜了
喜欢的小姐姐
就扣9块扣0
来这一款
瑕疵强力推荐
大家的这个T
时尚最百搭
不起球不变形不褪色
这款穿起来
就是滑滑的
凉凉的
来这一款
圆领圆领
大家这个T
咱们来量一下
胸围胸围98
可以拉伸到120都可以
它弹力大
长度的话是57
来这一款
谁要9块9块扣6
9圆9圆
谁要谁来扣个6
大家的这个T
时尚最百搭
哪个衣服里面漏了透了
需要搭一件
这个都可以去搭的
都可以去搭
来这个小马
呃
小马甲
针织的燕麦色
威灵
威灵看看
这一款咱们单穿叠穿都可以的
来胸围9298
长度来39来9块扣9
9块9块扣9细线
针织的薄薄的很薄很薄的溜薄的
这个9块扣9
9块扣个9
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块扣个9
来这个蓝的这个藏青的蓝的这个上衣
底下是灯楼式的
灯楼式的
来这款面料锯纸的面料锯纸圆领
来胸围胸围98100
来长度的话是52
长度52
来这款谁要9块9块扣2
9块9块谁要谁来扣个2
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9元9元扣2
来这款面料锯纸扣的面料锯纸
来这款面料锯纸扣是N6色
来这个小裙子
圆领圆领紫色的
紫色的这个腰身
圆领圆领啊
然后它的牌子是这个牌
牌子是这个牌子啊
来这款小裙子
看一下很好看的
来胸围胸围
八十八十六
腰围七十七十四
来裙长
八十六裙长八十六
来这个裙子谁要谁来扣
来二十九二十九扣个二
二十九
谁要谁来扣个二
紫色紫色的
来喜欢的姐姐就扣二十九扣个二
二十九扣个二
腰围多少
我没量腰围是不
我再给你量一下亲爱的
来胸围的话是
八十二九十
腰围的话是七十七十八
七十七十八
裙长八十六
86好好看呀
这条裙子是不好好看面料很软
面料好软
他这个应该是一个欧美单吧
应该是不是欧美单再见
小了再见
小了
我看
来这一款来给我们看一下原理原理这个灰色的
它是前面是个两层一层纱啊
一层这种薄薄的这种面料啊
来面料锯纸原理原理啊
来这款在中国破产了
真的假的
来胸围胸围九十六一百来长度五十三来九块九块抠三抠三喜欢的姐姐就给我九块抠三
苹果西葫芦在中国破产了
就
退回欧洲市场真的哦
是个欧美单对吧
来这一款卫衣
来给把我们看一下这款卫衣戴帽子的两边有口袋大大的啊
这个位移大这个位移大标拆掉了
没有标了啊
近距离给你看一下面料很好
看看面料很好
帽子上有出绳帽子上有 Tschusen
来
这个大大的位移戴帽子的带帽子的这一款来这一款两边有 qualche咋口袋两边有些啥都来胸围
胸围12012612096长度七十长 Buddha 70来这款二十929扣个2.29誰要谁来扣个二来这个
大大的这个位移啊
谁要谁来跟我很薄啊
不是特别厚
来谁要谁来够29扣个2
29扣个2
来这个绿色的这个卫衣
我觉得它很有特色
我看一下还有没有标
因为它是两种面料混合的
它是一个锯纸65
人棉30
聚氨纸5%
然后别布
你来啦
这个别布它是尼龙的
尼龙35
来这个它是这个牌
这个牌子的
来姐妹们看一下这个牌
这个牌这个牌
戴帽子的戴帽子的
烧好饭了
今天烧的啥
来帽子上有出绳
帽子上有出绳
它是一个前面短一点
后面长一点
帽子上有出绳
底边也有收的
看看后背是这样子的
后背这一块黑的
它是尼龙的
前面有口袋
来这一款我来量一下
胸围108 110
108 110
来长度
长度前面61
后面65
两面OK
来29 29
扣个2
29 29
谁要谁来扣个2
来喜欢的姐姐就扣29扣个2
29扣个2
我今天中午本来
我弟媳妇叫我去吃饭
然后她说吃兰州拉面
我说我不知道她家有凉面
然后我到那他们叫的凉面
我说早知道我也吃凉面了
吃这个面好热
两边有口袋
这个是佳融的
佳融的一个卫衣
SUR他们家的啊
SUR他们家的这个卫衣
这个咱们家老板自留的
刘老板自留
我看到他穿了
两边有口袋
前面这个字母啊
是是这种是这种泡泡的
是应该是焦音字母吧
泡泡的啊
来后背是这样子的
后背这样的
来佳融佳融的这一款
胸围
100 106
这个帽子上少出什么
有点微脏
长度的话
其实19吧
19扣1
19 19
谁要谁来扣
个一呀
谁要谁来扣个一
十几扣一呀
十九扣一呀
啊
发泡樱花啊
夏天吃汤面空调开足点
对啊
好热
但是在那个那个兰州拉面里面吃的
来这个牌这个牌子来给把我们看一下
这个牌
这个牌来米色啊
这个是米黄色吗
米黄色来这一款是一个
没有写什么码
巨值的面料是巨值的
这里有没有写没有写什么码
应该是均码的米色帽子上有出绳
帽子上有出绳
两边有口袋光板啊
简简单单大大方方的一个卫衣
前面有口袋来后背是这样子的
后背这样的来这一款卫衣
咱们来量一下
来胸围胸围一二六一三零一二六可以拉伸到一三零长度七十长度七十来这款谁要二十九二十九扣七二十九二十九扣七扣七
来这个小相风的这个圈直筒圈
左边有隐形拉链有封地扣的来这个圈这个圈直筒直筒的
没有标没有标了啊
这个腰围腰围八十二八十四
腿围一零八一一二一零八一一二来当场
啊不是裙长五十六来这个裙子九块九块扣六
九块九块扣六
先往啊
你们家饭搭的
天天就游泳
得晒黑了不
我跟你说走水里面
你你就是有阳光的地方
然后你在在水里边会说黑的很快的
来来来来
来吧
ICE
是
这个
就是积銀类布
这是这个
这个
就是积建类布
一下
kita
ة
nouve
一个
这样
非常
特别
鼓里
浓
撑
厉них
满
冰
葱
雪
crowd
门
秋
天
我们
怎么
不要
怎么
阳光的地方 我跟你说
我只能说分分钟给你
有的都晒泡不起
都晒成水泡
哎
去年是啥时候
你说你老公晒的
对吧
晒的很严重的是吧
晒的泡了是吧
啥时候
好像是你说的不
来 这个裙子来给宝们看一下
前面直伸 后面鱼尾
拒止的拒止的
腰式松紧腰
来 这一款咱们来量一下
你们听一下
腰为64
可以拉到88
臀为100
可以拉伸到102
100 102
寻常前面83
后面的话是86
来 这一款谁要谁的
给我说变成
又黑又瘦的小老头了
来 这一款
谁要谁的
谁要谁来扣
29 29扣个2
你们家那个瘦小
然后你高
对不对
我跟你说
就是一样的身高
女生要要显得比男生要高
要死我了
原本就尴尬巴巴的
这一赛就像这个
来 有酷有酷呀
你别把我们那个
我们一家子说的
那么那么
那个啥
看看爸爸说的那么可怜
把我们家大哥说的那么可怜
来这个带像十字袖一样的
棉纱的
有酷有酷呀
两边有口袋
来这一款咱们来量一下
腰为72
腿为102
裤长
来30
难得很多55分
来9块9块扣1呀
9块9块
谁要谁来扣个1呀
9块9块扣1扣1呀
9元9元扣个1
哎
这个灰色挺好看
来小黄油
这个黑色灰色挺好看的
看看
哎
没有写什么码
这上面写的啥7什么46
前天去帽子丢了
昨天去找说没了
来后面有隐形了
看来你不能给他买太贵的
对吧
来腰尾的话是78 80
腿尾的话是110 114
110 114
来我说
你是